[Música]
la realidad puede ser bella horrible la
podemos amar o detestar pero sobre todo
podemos tener ganas de cambiarla marín
ser una de las representantes de esta
nueva generación de almas creativas
combativas excepcionales está decidida a
reformar el sistema de la moda su
colección del verano 2021 no la está
presentando en una pasarela sino en esta
película que llamo amor fati el amor del
destino
con las de plasil
primero que todo es una elección en el
sentido en que no tenía ganas de pedirle
a nadie que tomara un avión se
desplazará por tan sólo 10 minutos de
show creo que los momentos que pasamos
sin poder viajar en alguna medida fue
una suerte una oportunidad de poner
pausa de parar al mismo tiempo no lo veo
como una limitación lo veo como algo
novedoso encontrar soluciones para
comunicar y crear
de hecho creo que comunicaremos más
cosas de las que podemos expresar
normalmente en un show toma más tiempo
madurar lo pero me gusta va de la mano
con los de todos venimos quiero tomarme
el tiempo para hacer las cosas bien por
eso las películas hablemos
con esta lesión y ha quebrado
amor fati en referencia a la célebre
locución de nietzsche indirectamente
mientras el filósofo nos propone no
aceptar tontamente nuestro destino sino
amar esta realidad caótica la diseñadora
trata de expresar como manejamos nuestra
vida cotidiana con frecuencia confusa y
tormentosa en especial en esta época de
pandemia nos invita a abrazar todas
nuestras emociones y sentimientos a
veces contradictorios sin negarlos ni
juzgarlos en este contexto como traduce
su reflexión en la vestimenta
en estas prendas lo que se conoce en el
medio de la moda como prendas
comerciales y sencillas solo quería
mostrar que finalmente era importante
contar con un vocabulario atlético y
bold con chance y como de costumbre
cuando creó diseño con la idea de
responderle a una cotidianidad a una
expectativa y la presente pero también a
un futuro era importante que estas
prendas hicieran parte de la nueva
colección y del show en el sentido en
que tenía ganas de que fueran prácticas
así fueron radicalmente sencillas
el hombre
la actualidad siempre inspiró a marín
ser y gusta el mayo de 2017 se llevó su
primer premio en el festival de llegar
esta colección está perico corporal
entonces de esta colección se llama
radical el for love y es un craig del
sports web con prendas y ropa de cultura
árabe es la idea de la ropa
contemporánea de algo que queremos
llevar ahora y es una colección que
llegó entre otras justo después de los
ataques de parís y bruselas radical code
for love es un llamado al amor es muy
simple de hecho
se hace está un profesor
el mismo año
para mí
rihanna le hace entrega del el vph price
el premio apoyo a la creatividad pero al
mismo tiempo a la gente que cuenta con
un verdadero sentido de los negocios
marín es una buena mezcla entre
creatividad y negocio no es porque es
una mujer no lo sé pero tendrá que tener
firmeza si quiere jugar a ese juego
qué ocurrirá ahora con este premio
buscamos un apartamento un poco más
grande un taller un poco más grande para
poder trabajar porque teníamos un
espacio muy pequeño entonces creo que es
la primera cosa por hacer y luego
remunerar al equipo que trabaja para mí
gratuitamente hasta ahora nadie recibía
remuneración
te muestro el otro diseño
tres años más tarde en 2020 sus trabajos
fueron recompensados nuevamente recibe
de parte de la an dama la asociación
para el desarrollo de las artes de la
moda una dotación de 200 mil euros que
les hace un reconocimiento a las
empresas de la moda que han facturado 10
millones de ellos
y
aquí recuperamos viejos topes vintage
hing de bordado y a partir de ello
construimos nuevos diseños y aquí tienen
diferentes partes del top y esto
normalmente era un escote que finalmente
fue ubicado en la cadera la idea es
llegar a un diseño híbrido entre diseño
cycles generated entre otros
aquí los tops de bordado que se asocian
con el jersey que es esta hibridación es
muy importante en la estética de la
marca y al mismo tiempo está el aspecto
práctico de solo descompactar así
estemos en una prenda muy costosa
las telas recuperadas son prendas de
segunda mano o tapetes lavados
desarmados cortados nuevamente bordados
o jerseys reciclados son concebidos a
partir de plásticos recuperados en los
océanos o lanas limpiadas y re tejidas
en prix la gallera donde nació hace 28
años era una semilla del tenis francés
pero finalmente prefirió las artes
aplicadas marín se despide audacia y
energía está lista para abrazar todos
los caos de la vida